so hallo also ich hab seit fünf jahren
zu sehen kann so ein ratschlag am hals
es tut ein bisschen weh wenn man drauf
drückt und er ist einfach über nacht
gekommen und nicht mehr weggegangen seit
fünf jahren ja war noch nie beim arzt
gewesen deswegen der wird auch nicht
größer oder so bleibt einfach da da ich
kein haudrauf auf diesen auf dieser
marke ja vielleicht könnt ihr mir sagen
was das sein könnte ja ein bisschen
bange
das ist was schlimmes ist aber andersrum
es ist da und du dich wesel und ganzen
können sie uns etwas dazu sagen muss er
sich sorgen machen wegen seines flex am
hals den er seit fünf jahren hat
natürlich eine sehr schwierige frage
weil man auf diesem bild wenig erkennen
kann was man in so einem fall sagen muss
ist wenn ein fleck über fünf jahre da
ist und sich nicht verändert egal was
man drauf schmiert dann sollte man den
kontrollieren lassen von einem
expertengespräch einem hautarzt im
wesentlichen denke ich dass es irgendwas
harmlose sein könnte möglicherweise ist
es so eine vorstufe einer aktinische
keratose das ist ein heller hautkrebs
aber ein völlig unbedenklicher so dass
wenn man den dann behandelt das
eigentlich schon wieder vorbei ist und
man sich keine wirklichen sorgen machen
muss denke alles was nicht wehtut und
über fünf jahre sich kaum verändert hat
kann so gravierend nicht sein
dennoch sollte man es abklären lassen
und das nicht per telemedizin sondern
wirklich analog also vor dem hautarzt
schauen wir mal auf die nächste 1
sendung die wir bekommen haben von
adrian trat er hat uns ein foto seines
vaters geschickt und hat dazu die frage
könnte das den hautkrebs sein
genau hier sehen wir das bild was können
sie daraus erkennen
in diesem fall würde ich dann jetzt ist
eine aktive sehr belastete haut das
bedeutet übersetzt dass der mensch sehr
viel sonne abbekommen hat das sehr viel
uv-strahlung auf dieser haut oder dieser
haut belastet hat sieht man an den
falten
das sieht man an den braunen flecken das
sind so genannte altersflecken die
sprechen auch immer eine gewisse sprache
das was ich so von hier erkennen kann
scheint mir eher eine sogenannte see
branche keratose zu
das wäre eine alte schwarze die hat mit
warze und viren nichts zu tun aber ist
eine völlig harmlose akkumulation also
vermengung von hautzellen hautschuppen
völlig harmloses zeug kann man einfach
kann man einfach lassen wenn es ihn sehr
stört beim unteren etwas helleren da
müsste ich einen genaueren blick werfen
und da würde ich jetzt zum beispiel mit
dieser meiner lupe gucken um ganz sicher
zu sein dass es sich um diese harmlose
alters war zu handelt und eben nicht um
irgend etwas anderes wir schauen mal in
die nächste zusendung von einer
zuschauerin rein
sie kommt von antje krüger sie ist 36
jahre alt vierfache mutter und sie hat
uns ein foto geschickt und schreibt dazu
ich habe seit circa vier jahren eine
merkwürdige wucherung am linken
mittelfinger
anfangs dachte ich an eine warze und sie
hat begonnen damit war zwar zehn mittel
aufzutragen aber anstatt kleiner zu
werden ist diese wucherung größer
geworden was könnte das bedeuten könnte
dass auch ein krebs sein oder welche
anzeichen sehen wir hier
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin denke ich auch
dass es eine virus warze ist das ist das
was sie vorhin gesagt hab virus warten
also warten sind halt viralen
erkrankungen und die können sich
natürlich aus denen und diese finger
warzen sind zum teil sehr unerlässlich
weil man sie manchmal schwer bändigen
kann was ich machen würde ist ich würde
mir diese hornhaut von einer fachperson
abtragen lassen dann noch mal mit diesem
jahr mattews coop mit der lupe nach
gucken lassen damit dass ich wirklich
recht aber was er dafür spricht sind
diese kleinen schwarzen pünktchen
diese kleinen schwarzen bündchen die man
sieht dass es tatsächlich nur was ganz
harmloses ist allerdings ansteckend je
nachdem mit wem man es zu tun hat
schauen wir mal auf die nächste 1
sendung die ist gekommen von thomas
lorenz und er hat seit einigen monaten
eine schuppige stelle am oberkörper
entschuldigung oberschenkel fast in
hüfthöhe und sie blutet weil er sie
immer wieder auf kratzt und salben
kortison und und heilsalbe
noch nicht geholfen die hautärztin erz
und sagt es ist nichts ernstes aber da
es nicht heilt macht er sich trotzdem
sorgen haben sie vielleicht noch ein
tipp für ihn ja ich sehe ich zwei von
diesen hautveränderungen
jetzt müsste man wissen wie viele von
ihnen gibt es noch das ist das was ich
zu beginn gesagt habe beim vorfuß zur
not kann man da eine probe nehmen und
dann dann da stand man oder schneidet
einfach 3 mm aus dieser hautveränderung
aus aber sie sehen ja da oben drüber auf
ein uhr ist ja eine zweite so dass man
fast denken sollte es müsste was
harmloser sein aber es kann natürlich
ein super fi celles basaliom sein könnte
auch eine aktinische keratose das kann
man so nicht beurteilen da muss man auch
anfassen und daneben hinter lupe gucken
und anfassen ist ja in der dermatologie
wir können nicht mehr als gucken und
tasten das ist so unsere unser metier
und dann müssen wir uns versichern und
durch andere untersuchungsmöglichkeiten
ein weiteres foto hat uns ernst fischer
aus hannover zugeschickt und er
beschreibt es auch als eine schwarze
stelle und er würde gerne wissen ob das
eher eine warze oder eher ein hautkrebs
sein könnte wenn ich meine patienten auf
diese entfernung angucken würde würden
sie sich zu recht beschweren
ich denke es ist eher eine symbolische
keratose also eine alte schwarze als ein
schwarzer hautkrebs ein melanom
dennoch muss man es anfassen man muss es
angucken und man muss einfach näheren
blick drauf haben der lage das ist auch
ein foto was uns ein zuschauer geschickt
hat frank kirche hat uns dieses foto des
lagers geschickt vielleicht die frage
noch mal an sie frau doktor simon das
was hat es mit nagel verfärbungen auf
sich ab wann hat das passt mit krebs zu
tun oder könnte das kann mit krebs zu
tun haben es ist nicht so sehr häufig
wobei ich nicht so gut bin den zahlen
wie die kollegin von der
selbsthilfegruppe dennoch das was da ist
scheint mir das kommt nicht von der
struktur von der wachs struktur des
nagels von daher denke ich dass das mit
einem hautkrebs erst mal nichts zu tun
melanom nichts zu tun hat am nagel
wenn man schwarze streifen hat die quasi
aus der nähe aus der nagel wachstumszone
kommen dann sollte man die schon
begutachten lassen
manchmal sind es nur kleine einblutungen
weiß dass es die günstigste variante
weil ein schuh zu eng war oder weil der
absatz zu hoch war das gibt es häufiger
mal aber wenn der streifen tatsächlich
von 100 oder gewandert ist dann sollte
man das schon an gucken lassen
sicherlich und zur not muss man eben
auch wieder eine probe nehmen